ein schloss ok alles klar ysl sud
kämpfen hallo mein name ist luca und
herzlich willkommen wir heute zu einem
neuen video ihr seht wahrscheinlich
schon längst alles von der belichtung so
ein bisschen anders ich habe eine neue
fenster mit am start und hey ich hatte
pizza zum frühstück mein leben ist
perfekt
wir befinden uns die auf der website
quickdrop also auf deutsch übersetzt
schnellzeichner etwas kenne newell
network landtag rudels das wird ein
härtetest bei playing also dass auf
deutscher seite keine arbeit da kann
eigentlich schläger ich versuch's mal
das was die website quasi macht ist uns
ein wort vorgeben was bezeichnen sollen
und die website erregern danach ob es
das wort wahr hört sich irgendwie dummen
weil die website uns das wort ja
vorgegeben hat ob es dieses spiel ist
von google von den entwicklern von
google und das ist in so ein test wiegen
und die wollen irgendwie schauen wie
chlor und wir fangen einfach an wir
kriegen jetzt einfach mal auf letzte und
jetzt bekommen wir beispielsweise roller
skates eingeblendet jetzt jetzt klopft
eine an der tür ein paar sekunden später
ok meine damen und herren weiter geht
roller skates und andere tonis ex ok
gerade das heißt wir müssen jetzt diese
dinge es hier mal mitrollen runter auch
umts roller skates was
als er kugel bevor du das erraten willst
lernen doch erst mal englisch jetzt muss
ich einen teddybär zeichnen in 20
sekunden das heißt ich würde das dann
irgendwie sowas lager denn die ganze
zeit hier die dinge es hier so tag hier
kriegt er vielleicht noch einen dingen
sondern den in den ländlichen panda baby
molly nomaden schneeband sorry i call
you gc lernen englisch google jetzt muss
ich einen augen unter 20 sekunden
zeichen das sollte eigentlich relativ
easy machbar sein also so die tsa
wir machen das ganze ist ein bisschen
spannender und zwar immer wenn google
das wort erwähnt ist alles tut aber wenn
google das wort nicht er rät muß ich mir
eine backpfeife geben
lässt du diese tue ich das eigentlich
ich tue mir nur selbst wählen einen
oktopus okay ich weiß nicht mal wie ein
octopus aussieht ich glaube jetzt
irgendwie so so so so hier nochmals
octopus
wir verstehen uns bitte eine mail box
und damit ist nicht die mailbox gemeint
auf dem telefon sondern die die vor der
haustür steht also dann machen wir mal
so machen wir hier so ein fähnchen 3d
white house lighthouse wissen bescheid
komme ich mache jetzt sogar noch neue
tür rein damit man das ets mailbox
ein schloss ok alles klar ich sollen
schloss mal lasst mich doch gleich die
mona lisa malen so gut kennt das ist ein
schloss alter okay ich mache hier noch
im turm dran und einmal hier so sagt
keine kirche so genannten dingsda das
ganze auch nicht
man hat doch und das was ein schloss ist
oh [ __ ] a
[ __ ] my life das tut wohl gerade wir
machen noch ne runde jetzt soll ich
einen becher in 20 sekunden malen das
sollte eigentlich recht easy machbar
sein ich mache erst mal das hier oben
und dann in ots cup
es gab einen hammer in unserer 20
sekunden sollte ich mich selber zeichnen
oder was rot blau rasch ohne ihr gang
sorry i co
t
er hatten hammer nicht erkannt auftakt
mylife glas sind anatomisch sex okay das
sollte eigentlich die macht war sein so
sagt sack wien ots e klasse
[Musik]
zeichne einen tornado in unter 20
sekunden sollten sie machbar sei
natürlich einfach idee ist tornado
[Musik]
zeichne ein bett in unter 20 sekunden ok
das sind die die macht war so hier
packen man die matratze drauf dann
machen wir hier in portixol hingehst
betglocke du dich schon mal so zur info
ich habe das ganze bei der nie gesehen
also checkt auf jeden fall denn erstens
video dazu abfall nicht mehr witzig und
habe das ok wie oft schaffe ich das
einfach mal zeichne eine vasen unter 20
sekunden sollte eigentlich auch easy
macht war sein also mache ich das ganze
mal so minow ots vase
idee ist
ich kann nicht beschreiben wie geil ich
bin zeichne einen finger in unter 20
sekunden also so kann man sich einen
finger mal richtig groß damit er das
irgendwie weiß so liegt sie saw
ostermarkt
oh wow was für vallori gc
er hatte gedacht das war ein wal dir mal
ein bild von einem finger und das ist
ein wal seht ihr da irgendeine
ähnlichkeit ja eigentlich schon
halt halt deine schnauze des uk
santander tonis ex ok sollte auch easy
machbar sein man von war einfach so hier
eine halterung und hier die rolle
bottrop
es war direkt erraten da kannst du mal
deine schnauze halten man denkt
vielleicht ok desto mehr die website er
rät ist die schwierigere sachen kommen
ran
ich muss jetzt ein viereck zeichnen wow
ja algarve und jetzt zeichne ich so eine
idee ist wer bleibt man das video wenn
es euch gefällt ist cool kann ich mir
zwar nichts verkaufen aber like geben
ist cool hier eine ananas 21 sekunden
also dann machen wir so hier machen wir
das oben mal dran und jetzt macht mal
jedoch ein paar von den teilen dran und
so ich bin der beste
ohne spaß stellt mich neben picasso und
ich bin einfach nur ein kleiner scheißer
neben picasso mein leben wir schon
eigentlich bemitleidenswert ein
telefonen unter 20 sekunden
das sollte machbar sein so so
und jetzt so easy cat scheiße easy fold
riklin gesagt kann man liegend will im
boden
eine couch in unter 20 sekunden ok go
wie macht man eine kaufen sollte man im
kautschuk und erkennt dass dann ohrringe
ringe tor alarm sowie kultur gc hält
eine strafe denn erst mal englisch
auch wieder schreiben mir immer wenn ich
das mit diesem wachsweichen machte joker
da gibt's ja gar keine richtige
bachseite schlag doch mal richtig zu wie
wäre es wenn ihr das auch einfach mal
machen wenn ihr schon rummeckern ich
probiere es noch einmal jetzt alle
sachen richtig zu haben ein
schraubenzieher in unter 20 sekunden
okay das heißt nicht mal fangen den
ganzen schaden sagt er muss man hier mit
draußen geben das heißt wenn man so
umdrehen kann man den damit raus wie
kann man das unerwartet hohe flamingo
das ist nicht meine schuld ich sehe es
nicht einmal dafür eine zu klatschen das
habe ich super gut aufgemalt und wenn
google das liegt auch eine gitarre okay
gut das sollte ich jetzt wohl hinkriegen
okay so sagt sack
so hier sind die seiten so die tsa
seine nase in unter 20 sekunden okay so
ein baum okay sie so das ist diese
stammen und hier kommt obendrauf
mich verarschen google einst am tornado
wasser tornado hurricanes der hurrikan
ist keine schlange hockeypark
sorry info hafencity das was jetzt auch
schon vom video meine damen und herren
wenn es euch gefallen hat last auf jeden
fall mal leichter und bei 100000 likes
dann schenke ich euch über handy mit
allen daten drauf
das glaubt dir selbst schuld ihr findet
irgendwo um mich rum gerade ein smiley
eingeblendet wenn ihr darauf könnte
meinen kanal abonnieren und ihr findet
auch ein video eingeblendet das ist
nämlich war teil zwei von gestern schaut
euch das auf jeden fall mal an mega cool
geworden mega spannendes video und ja
derzeit vermin
[Musik]